si dans cette raffinerie est susceptible
de l'être
cette partie baptiste girardet donne ses
consignes et il est ce qu'on pourrait
appeler un nettoyeur de crime
pourtant depuis la crise sanitaire le
fondateur de la société sang froid à
adapter quelque peu son activité il
s'est lancé dans la désinfection iroko
vite 19 ou désinfectant les habitats
privé pour les gens qui reviennent de
ranimation et qui ont eu écho vide qui
ont la chance de revenir chez eux mais
essentiellement pour la partie
commerçants artisans qui doivent
pérenniser finalement leur activité
quand cela est permis de manière à
désinfecter leurs environnements de
travail ce jour-là baptiste girard des
intérêts bien chez deux commerçants l'un
à coignières et l'autre à rambouillet au
programme désinfection de l'ensemble de
leurs locaux et traitement à l'ozone
non c'est vrai qu'on brasse un petit peu
plus de monde du coup les gens je
préfère qu'ils sentent en sécurité en
nombre de magasins entre guillemets la
clientèle nous je vire donc je pense que
c'est important d'en prendre soin pour
nous ce qui est important c'est que l'on
soit serein que nos clients aussi qu'ils
soient rassurés qu'on puisse avoir des
lieux saints depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire sang froid a réalisé 170
interventions
créée en 2017 ce n'est pourtant pas sa
mission première de venir nettoyeur de
crimes n'étaient pas forcément non plus
la vocation initiale de baptiste
girardet d'abord pompiers de paris
pendant 11 ans puis criminaliste y siens
de sécurité intérieure dans la police
scientifique pendant trois années
il a tout lâché pour créer son
entreprise un jour j'en ai eu marre j'en
ai eu marre de
aussi bien de voir dans parcours ton
pied que dans le parcours police
scientifique des familles des gens
désoeuvrés
en attendant un service qui n'existait
pas qui justement un service qui puisse
effacer les traces de la mort une fois
qu'on est décédé on rentre dans un état
de putréfaction le corps pourri
finalement et donc laisse des traces les
fluides humains qui sont contenus dans
le corps
s'échappe pas gravité donc il y en a sur
le sol sur le mobilier sur lequel repose
le départ cette décision il l'a prise en
toute connaissance de cause l'idée
d'être nettoyeur de crime fait suite à
deux drames familiaux qu'il a vécu en
2003 et 2004 2003 c'était aussi la date
d'entrée à laquelle j'ai été incorporé
chez les pompiers de paris
donc on découvrait nombre de cadavres
tous les jours due à la canicule
justement et je me suis tout de suite
posé cette question je pouvais pas
présager que quelques semaines plus tard
j'allais faire la douloureuse expérience
de des fluides de mon grand-oncle que
j'ai dû moi-même nettoyer puisque le
bailleur parisien m'a donné 10 jours
pour vider un appartement parisien
aujourd'hui la société sont froids en
bouche quatre personnes à plein temps et
fait appel à des freelances lorsque
l'émission s'accumulent partis se former
au canada baptiste girardet espère bien
un jour voir une formation de nettoyeur
de crime naître en france